[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHRADDHA PANDEY: Sustainability,
energy efficiency,
and green development.
These are fundamental
to the modern cities
of today and tomorrow.
Hi.
I'm Shraddha Pandey,
and in this video
I will be discussing about the
role of green building rating
systems in city
sustainability, by analyzing
the impact of green
building index, as a system,
on the future of green
buildings in Malaysia.
Let us start by understanding
what green buildings are,
and why rating
systems are important.
Infrastructure is indispensable
to the growth and development
of a society.
And key components
of it are buildings.
Buildings use energy for
lighting, space, heating,
or cooling, ventilation,
air conditioning,
and other electronic and
electrical appliances.
Collectively buildings
can consume around
40% of the total energy
around the world,
including energy usage
during construction,
as well less in their
operational phase.
Efficient energy use, and
a conducive environment
in and around the buildings
is critical to city
sustainability.
So what is a green building?
How is a green building, or
an energy efficient building,
different from a
conventional one?
A green building is a building
whose construction and lifetime
of operation assure the
healthiest possible environment
by making the most efficient
and least disruptive
use of land, water,
energy, and resources.
Some of the features that
define a green building
include climate responsive
nature of its architecture,
passive techniques for heating,
cooling, ventilation and day
lighting, use of renewable
sources of energy,
efficient and environment
friendly practices
during construction
and post occupancy,
use of [INAUDIBLE] materials,
and occupant health, safety,
and comfort.
An efficiently
designed green building
can save up to 30% to
60% energy as compared
to that by a conventional
building which
is not environment sensitive.
LESLIE NORFORD: are an
important part of that,
particularly in developing
countries where they use maybe
a third to 40% of
national energy resources,
and a significantly higher
percentage of electricity,
over 70% in the US.
Lighting is a major
energy consumer
in commercial buildings.
Another major energy
consumer, particularly
in tropical areas, where large
numbers of the world's people
live, is cooling.
Shading for windows, more
efficient cooling systems,
and use of what's called natural
ventilation at times of year
when outdoor conditions permit.
SHRADDHA PANDEY:
However, if we hope
to align the benefits
of green buildings
with the sustainability
of a city
and optimize energy use
by buildings globally,
every designer
and developer will
need to be aware and
work towards creating
energy efficient buildings.
Only then shall
[INAUDIBLE] energy saving.
And that is where the
green integrating systems
play a very important role.
They can be used as a tool
to encourage and enforce
the building of
green structures.
These may be either in form
of certifications or mandate
records.
LESLIE NORFORD:
Now, we might ask
how the countries
and governments,
nonprofit agencies, promote the
development of green buildings.
And two big elements of that are
standards and rating systems.
And rating systems have
increasingly shown their value
in many countries
by calling attention
to the value of green buildings,
and giving building owners,
building operators clear,
easy to understand targets
for construction features
and for operation
of their buildings.
They're not perfect.
They tend not to be
overly quantitative.
And one can get a
good rating, maybe
in some cases for aspects of the
building that don't necessarily
save energy but are
important environmentally.
But their popularity
is hugely important.
This works well at
city level, and larger.
People can see that neighboring
buildings are part of this.
Work in one country can
help, the development work,
can help make it
easier for neighboring
countries with similar
climates to do the same.
SHRADDHA PANDEY: There
are various rating systems
developed and being followed
in different countries
around the world.
While designing green buildings,
the site, surroundings,
climate, resources, and
building function all
play a crucial role.
And thus, every
rating system needs
to be contextual and unique in
its response to the location,
climate, and resource
availability of the area
that it has been designed for.
Green Building Index
Malaysia, launched in 2009,
is a green building
rating system
developed by Malaysian
Institute of Architects
and the Association of
Consulting Engineers Malaysia.
It is a comprehensive
rating system
for evaluating the environmental
design and performance
of buildings on six main
criterion under seven
different categories.
VON KOK LEONG: GBI
is just another tool
to actually help
to spread awareness
throughout the country, which
is why we also so formed
the Malaysia Green Building
Confederation, or MGBC, whose
role is to actually spread
awareness of sustainability
throughout the
whole country, not
just to designers, but to other
stakeholder organizations.
So we worked together with MGBC
in promoting other areas apart
from accreditation.
And we consider that
moving towards green
is a natural step for
designers to know.
THIRUKUMARAN
JALLENDRAN: The industry
is responding in the
manner it should.
So I'm quite hopeful that
again in the last five years
we've gone from
0 green buildings
to about 627 green buildings.
So that's an indication of
where the market's right now.
So I'm quite encouraged
with this development.
And they see that through
GBI, through a green building
certification, there's value
added to their development,
to their projects.
The projects are performing
environmentally better
than projects which
are not GBI certified.
That is one.
Secondly, they also
see the benefits
through operational savings.
So they use less energy.
They use less water,
less utilities.
They produce less waste.
GBI boasts to have
successfully achieved
100 million square feet
of green rated built up
area in the past five
years in Malaysia.
As imperative it is to
have a system in place,
it is equally vital to
comprehend the approach
and response of the building
developers and designers
towards it to ensure
that we achieve
our aim of having more
sustainable green buildings
in the future.
GBI takes a holistic approach
and covers many aspects
that facilitate the design and
construction of an environment
friendly building, grading
them on a 100 point system.
To assess the impact
of GBI as a system,
the criterion on which
the buildings are rated
was sorted into two broad
categories, short term impact,
and long term impact.
The categorization depends
on whether the criterion
helps keeps the building green
for its expected lifetime.
Long term impact
criterion are mostly
part of the physical
structure and design
of the building itself.
And their energy benefits can
be gained year after year.
For example, if skylights are
incorporated in the building
envelope as a passive
design feature
to optimize the use of daylight.
Or if advanced energy
performance measures,
and innovative
design initiatives
are included at the conception
and construction phase,
their benefits last
for a lifetime.
However, other measures,
like worker side amenities,
or construction waste
management are also important.
But these are examples of
short term impact criterion,
as they do not ensure the
effective energy efficiency
and environmental gain
repeatedly in the coming years.
GBI has rated around
300 buildings since 2009
in Malaysia.
The study was conducted
for the existing GBI
non-residential new
construction code.
It was identified that
out of a total 100,
57 points account for long
term impact criterion,
and 43 for short term
impact criterion.
In the past years,
GBI has certified
112 buildings in
the NRNC category
under the four classifications.
Out of these almost
50% of the buildings
have applied for and
received green certification
under the rated classification,
which requires only 50 points,
suggesting that the
majority of buildings
aim for and receive this
basic level of certification.
And it may be important to
note that these buildings can
acquire 84% of their points
from the short term impact
criterion.
It is evident from
the data from GBI
that these building tend to
acquire points from short term
impact criterion
more, suggesting
that most of the
buildings rated green
would not be very different
from the conventional ones
during their lifespan.
So the buildings
may be called green,
but in reality might not
have the expected impact
on energy use optimization
in Malaysian cities.
Also identified
were the criterion
which seemed to be most
achievable and non achievable
by the buildings.
Less than 20% of
the rated buildings
could achieve few of the major
criterion in the long term
impact category.
It is interesting
to see that these
account for almost 25 points
in the 100 point system.
And the points achieved by more
than 80% of the rated buildings
have a substantial share of the
short term impact criterion.
However, from the examples
of platinum, gold, and silver
rated buildings,
we see that it is
possible to achieve better
efficiency within the GBI
framework.
To encourage and enforce
that on a larger scale
a few improvisations
can be made.
Following are suggestions
specific to GBI existing NRNC
code.
Malaysian standard MS
1525 is the Malaysian code
of practice for energy
efficiency and use
of renewable energy for
non-residential buildings.
Compliance to it should be
introduced as a prerequisite
for a GBI rating.
Among the points
achieved by buildings,
the percentage requirement
for long term criterion
should be specified, making
sure that the buildings achieve
a balance of both.
A minimum number of long term
criterion points required
should be fixed to apply for
silver, gold, and platinum
certification.
A few of the
identified criterion
are vital for human health,
comfort, and environment
protection, therefore
should be made mandatory
to apply for GBI certification.
The weightage of
long-term impact criterion
can be increased.
This will reinforce
their importance,
and higher efforts would be put
by developers to achieve them.
The number of points allotted
for innovation criterion
should be increased.
This encourage designers
to be creative and make
proper analysis of the
behavior of the designs
and specifications.
Innovation should be
encouraged in design,
rather than just being
limited to technology,
by equally dividing innovation
points among building design
features and technology
incorporation.
Learning the lessons from
the examples of environment
sensitive buildings in Malaysia,
and looking at their climate
responsive architectural
design and solutions
can be one of the most
effective ways of doing this.
These buildings have been built
for the Malaysian climate,
with features like solar buffer
effect, solar shading devices,
day lighting, terraced
gardens, and orientation
driven ventilation.
These are a few of the
celebrated environment
sensitive buildings in Malaysia.
Encouraging architects
to apply these features
under innovative
design criterion, which
promote the use of climate
responsive architecture,
these suggestions may help bring
about substantial benefits,
and create more green buildings,
having higher efficiency
through the green building
index in Malaysia.
And GBI can become a guiding
tool for buildings in Malaysia
to sustain their energy
efficient character
throughout their lifespan.
In the next 50 years
our energy demands
globally will be doubled.
Hence, energy saving has become
the need of the [? Earth. ?]
Green building rating systems
are the way towards a greener,
more comfortable, and more
efficient future of our
build environment.
By developing more
effective rating systems
we can ensure the quality
of our build environment,
and hence, shape a
sustainable future
for our cities of tomorrow.
Our future is our
responsibility.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BIRDS CHIRPING]